[Musik]
[Applaus]
hitler hat befohlen aller rheinbrücken
zu sprengen
hier sollte alliierte vormarsch zum
stehen kommen aber eine brücke blieb
intakt die brücke von remagen
der form der westlichen armeen ergießen
sich auf der rechten rheinufer
[Musik]
remagen in rheinland pfalz die
weltberühmte ludendorff brücke vor fast
77 jahren wurde der ort zum sinnbild der
befreiung und des untergangs des dritten
reiches die
reste der ludendorff brücke heute an
beiden seiten des rheins stehen noch die
imposanten türme am westufer wurden sie
zum friedensmuseum die brücke gibt es
seit ihrem einsturz am 17 märz
1945 nicht mehr zehn tage zuvor hatten
angehörige der neunten us panzerdivision
den letzten intakten übergang erobert
der weg für die erste us armee war frei
18 alliierte regimenter strömen richtung
ruhrgebiet der todesstoß für hitlers
drittes reich heute kommen die befreier
von 1 zurück an diesen historischen ort
eine gruppe us veteranen allesamt fast
100 jahre alt sie besuchen die orte von
angst trauer und heldenmut ein letztes
mal
treffen hier auch auf einen ehemaligen
feind ein moment der versöhnung und des
friedens
einer der us veteranen ist der ehemalige
fahnder beugt jagdflieger at
verjagte mit seiner maschine damals des
wehrmachts leutnants jürgen tegethoff
nun stehen sie seite an seite
ich bin 99 jahre alt ich glaube nicht
dass ich noch mal jemals hier sein werde
ich würde ihn hier aber gern noch einmal
wiedersehen
der schwer umkämpften rheinübergang die
lupen dorfbrücke tausende soldaten
starben an beiden seiten des ufers im
märz 45 tegethoff wartete mit panzern im
westen die amerikaner kamen immer näher
als junger pilot flog leuten und
cottrell damals insgesamt 65 einsätze in
der b47 maschine zu hause wartete seine
schwangere frau
darüber gekommen um die deutschen daran
zu hindern die brücke doch noch zu
sprengen unsere aufgabe war es
artillerie und schlag zu zerstören so
dass sie unsere bomber nicht runter
holen konnten
sie hatten hier freie schussbahn und
eine gute höhe die haben wir versucht
auszuschalten
aber ich weiß nicht ob wir sie getroffen
haben oder nicht
auch der ehemalige fallschirmjäger der
siebzehnte airborne division bot white
als private first class kämpfte der mann
aus virginia am d day in der normandie
der ardennen schlacht und sprang am 24
märz 45 östlich des rheins über wesel
aus seinem lastensegler ins feindliche
gebiet mehr als 70 jahre später erhielt
der veteran mit den sanften lächeln
dafür den bronx es da eine hohe
auszeichnung des us militärs weit steht
am rhein zückt sein iphone fotografiert
für seine familie daheim den blick in
seine eigene geschichte
ich wurde in england zum
fallschirmspringer ausgebildet ich
gerieten als battle of the ball dann
sprangen wir am rhein ab ich weiß leider
gerade nicht auf welcher seite es
war ein bisschen traurig wieder
herzukommen weil wir hier so viele
kameraden verloren haben
[Musik]
als wir dann hier waren waren die
menschen sehr freundlich zu mir
ich glaube sie waren froh dass wir sie
befreit haben wie wir das auch mit
anderen ländern geschafft haben vor im
friedensmuseum hält die us truppe in die
rückkehr nach deutschland wurde
organisiert vom bestseller autorin rubio
einem jungen afghanistan veteranen er
überzeugte auch l blaney zur rückkehr
sein spitzname
doch
ich habe in der 326 medical company
gedient und wir gehörten zum 101
airborne
was er heute bei der rückkehr nach
deutschland führt bei einem wiedersehen
mit seinem gegner von damals den panzer
kommandanten jürgen taeger
ich freue mich dass wir uns doch einmal
wiedersehen als sich deutschland 1948
das letzte mal verlassen habe war ich
mir sicher nie wieder zu
uns aber ich hatte die chance dass sich
der ehemalige airborne sanitäter in
zukunft wünscht
ich weiß nicht was die zukunft bringt
vielleicht will ich das auch gar nicht
wissen
für die veteranen white und blaney ist
die rückkehr nach deutschland auch die
einlösung eines versprechens
vor zwei jahren hatten die beiden us
helden im belgischen bastogne den
ehemaligen königstiger leutnant jürgen
tegethoff getroffen sich für ein
wiedersehen verabredet
vor 77 jahren stoppten bei der agenten
schlacht hunderttausende alliierte
soldaten hitlers groß angelegte letzten
offensive
das örtchen bastogne war dabei hart
umkämpft denn
[Musik]
das turnier werden die jahrestage in
jedem jahr gefeiert die geschäfte sind
geschmückt die befreier von damals sind
hier noch immer helden aus königswinter
reiste der frühere wehrmachtsoffizier
und spätere richter und
bundesverdienstkreuzträger dr jürgen
tegethoff im dezember 2009 10 zu seinen
früheren gegnern sie begrüßten ihn wie
einen alten freund es war ein starkes
zeichen der versöhnung alte männer
zeigten eine neugier aufeinander wie
jungs die angst der hass von damals sie
haben keinen platz mehr im leben der
soldaten von einst beim treffen was
tonne entstand dieses ikonische foto
praktiker torf und pläne es ging um die
welt und hängt heute bei vielen
veteranen in den wohnzimmern
in remagen ist die gruppe zum essen
direkt am rhein verabredet das
restaurant heißt wacht am rhein ein name
mit symbolcharakter als deckname diente
der titel des berühmten liedes aus der
kaiserzeit im jahr 1944 für die
ardennenoffensive es gibt kölsch für die
gruppe currywurst für die amerikaner
wieder sitzen die gegner von damals
gemütlich zusammen
dann zeigt der frühere panzeroffizier
den gästen einen persönlichen schatz
sein foto tagebuch des krieges jürgen
tegethoff hat es 1945 vor den
anrückenden amerikanern retten und
verstecken können noch nie hatten die
soldaten einen solchen einblick in die
persönliche geschichte ihrer gegner der
ehemalige panzer jäger r schaut sich
jede seite mit interesse an der
restaurantbesuch ist eine kleine pause
für die gruppe auf ihrer tour an die
orte ihre eigenen geschichten und der
weltgeschichte
nach der pause am rhein geht es weiter
sagt pilot coach l beschäftigen die
fotos die sein damaliger todfeind
gezeigt hat mit seiner tochter susan
macht er sich auf zum bus die reise geht
weiter am ufer nutzen die veteranen und
ihre ehrenamtlichen begleiter die zeit
für erinnerungsfotos von einem ruhigen
friedvollen rhein ein moment der stille
breit gehen die emotionalen momente der
aufregenden tage nicht aus dem kopf in
einem restaurierten us geht macht sich
der fallschirmjäger auf eine besondere
suche der ort seiner landung im märz
1945 nahe wiese
ich hörte hier jemanden rufen dass er da
hängt ich schaute mich umsah nichts der
hang mit seinem fallschirm sehr hoch
es gab keinen weg liegende abschneiden
konzert hätte ich ihnen da abgeschnitten
wären wir beide abgestellt
ich wollte dann hilfe für meine
kameraden organisieren
das letzte an das ich mich erinnern kann
er rief die verdammten werden mich
erschießen wenn ich hier so hänge
boxer seinen kameraden nie wieder
auch den ehemaligen fahnder bob piloten
schmerzen die erinnerungen
jahrzehntelang suchte er nach seinem
guten freund und kameraden bis zu diesem
besuch an einem ort der stille auf dem
belgischen soldatenfriedhof fand der
kampfpilot nach 77 jahren seinen buddy
wieder ein besonders emotionaler moment
für den fast 100 jährigen niemand hatte
ihm vorher gesagt dass die recherchen
nach dem verbleib des freundes
erfolgreich waren rtl wusste nicht dass
ihn diese reise auch an die letzte
ruhestätte von leugnen tests mit führt
am ersten januar wurde unsere
staffellauf mission geschickt einer
meiner freunde teds mit bei der führer
der staffel von vier maschinen
er wurde vom schlag getroffen er zog die
maschine hoch aber es reichte nicht für
einen sprung heraus
das flugzeug heute nicht weiterfliegen
und er stürzt ab wurde getötet ich habe
zwei gute freunde in meiner einsatzzeit
hier
bad camberg
der soldatenfriedhof in ittenbach daher
von königswinter die
deutsch-amerikanische kolonne erreicht
den ort der für alle beteiligten ein
platz der trauer ist in den letzten
kriegstagen wurden hier zunächst
tausende us soldaten bestattet sie
werden später umgebettet oder in ihre
heimat überführt
nach den amerikanern wurden anfang 45
tausende deutsche in ittenbach beerdigt
noch heute ruhen mehr als 1800 deutsche
soldaten hier der jüngste von ihnen
starb mit gerade einmal 15 jahren kinder
friedhof nennen diesen ort im
idyllischen welchen viele jürgen
tegethoff und seine amerikanischen
freunde nutzen den ort für ein zeichen
der versöhnung
ich habe kein problem damit auch wenn er
damals auf uns geschossen hat
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wer ein gerät die beiden gegner von
damals wollen nicht nur sitzen sie
wollen sich gegenüberstehen die hand
geben rob white klopft dem deutschen
gegner von einst auf die schulter das
sind gesten der versöhnung und des
vergehens nach 77 jahren reichen sich
die soldaten von damals die hände
und dann blitzt es auf die neugier der
hunger nach dem warum und die fragen die
auch noch nach 80 jahren bleiben panzer
jäger at will vom königstiger
kommandanten wissen wie er ihn damals
hätte ausschalten können
das einzige was wir wussten war dass die
panzer so robust waren dass die kugel
ihn gar nichts anhaben konnten sondern
nur die bomben
alpen
[Gelächter]
was sind die gefühle die sie von hier
mitnehmen
ich bin glücklich all diese geschichten
gehört zu haben von der anderen seite
von unserem gegner
es war interessant die details von
panzer kommandanten zu hören
ich habe es genossen ihn zu treffen und
diese seite der geschichte zu hören
die feinde von einst verlassen den
friedhof ihrer freunde gemeinsam sie
alle haben ihren frieden gefunden
die veteranen steigen wieder in ihren
bus darauf steht der eifel das gewehr es
ist der titel eines buchs in dem ihre
geschichten und erlebnisse des krieges
für die nachwelt aufgeschrieben sind
unzählige geschichten ihrer kameraden
die auf diesem friedhof liegen und lagen
sind für immer verloren
auch jürgen tegethoff verabschiedet sich
der frühere richter will sich weiter
dafür einsetzen dass die schrecken des
krieges nicht vergessen werden
[Musik]